et j'accueille maintenant dans l'amp les
ailes bonsoir vous dire on m'avait dit
que j'étais jolie mais travailler on
n'avait pas raconter d'histoires
magnifique du pot luchini lui je suis
rigoureux et de sa côte est de l'île et
à la fin on va jusqu'à l'envoi le couche
pardonnez moi j'étais persuadé dans mon
cliché d'ilan halimi
je croyais que vous étiez vous savez une
grande fête du sport en plus et d'un
sport hyper noble donc là ça devient
très très très lent alors rocade on
comprend là vous avez du bol parce que
vous avez une technique maîtrisée parce
que c'est hyper dur y parle kane un
mysticisme nous quand on fait le jeu là
défilant peau des films en costumes on
nous apprend qu'à relief ça des gens qui
nous apprend on est incapable ou prend
les ethnies incapable mais quand on sait
qu'on a en face de nous une femme qui
maîtrise a acquis et éblouissante de
beauté ou le 10 novembre
alors mes amis mesdames messieurs chers
amis c'est pas vrai mais paix dans le
mirail a juste 2 millions de gens qui
veulent savoir qui l'on a fait c'est par
exemple le 3 novembre 1999 laura flessel
est devenue championne du monde des
scream
je suis fasciné par vol ah bon alors
vous êtes en plus favorite pour les jeux
olympiques de sydney tout à fait on fait
pour le moment c'est moi qui détiens les
les titres en fait de chanter double
championne olympique donc sont des
titres à défendre donc dans dix mois on
verra ce que ça va donner
ouais alors vous aimez bien faire de la
télé vous avez bien patienter vous avez
dit je suis d'une nature curieuse et à
force d'être tout le temps passif devant
la télévision et à regarder a critiqué
des émissions j'ai voulu voir le travail
en amont
oui tout à fait donc voilà ça c'est un
plateau les cameramans regarder les
cadreurs alors je leur ai dit bonjour en
passant donc cédric arrêté de sa fille
seule alors vous êtes né à pointe à
pitre 1 pointe à pitre 100 watts bouba
diop
non mais toi tu savais j'ai finalement
jeté son dévolu à la martinique
vous avez commencé la danse à 6 ans à
l'âge de 6 ans et un jour vous voyez
jean françois lamour à la télévision en
fait j'étais fasciné par les films de
cape et d'épée plusieurs règlements a
commencé avec ivanhoe non plus l'enfant
lassus l'ip les trois mousquetaires le
bossu donc le dessus donc de fil en
aiguille un jour j'ai vu une
rétrospective de match de sabre c'était
pour moi des scream moderne et le
lendemain je me trouvais dans un club et
c'est parti comme ça ça à faire enfin de
trois ans comme toi quand tu as vu un
film de cul lelangue manager d'un club
dont vous avez été plusieurs fois
championne de guadeloupe on vous appelle
la guêpe wee man de parme jeudi à m
ma petite taille lorsque j'ai commencé
les scream c'est vrai que j'étais fille
filiforme
mais j'avais déborder d'énergie c'est
que tout savoir c'est que à l'origine
j'étais un petit garçon manqué donc je
mangeais l'essence et d'un coup en fait
ma première compétition je ne
connaissais que de coups et on m'a dit
tant qu'il n'ya pas haïti continue tu
vas chercher la touche et en fait
c'était assez folklorique parce que la
fille elle était plaquée sur le mieux et
moi je continue à appliquer demain c'est
arrivé aussi partie alors vous êtes
devenu vous êtes venus alors arrivé en
france en choeur enfin métropole pardon
en cadets nés en 90 91 7 il faut savoir
c'est que j'étais déjà détecté mais
j'avais pas envie je me sentais pas
suffisamment prêtes pour quitter ma
famille quitter le département le soleil
et venir ici donc j'ai dit que en fait
je viendrai après le bac donc à 18 ans
avec le bac il fallait qu'on une
décision partir et c'est arrivé ici vous
dites j'ai été laissé en marge
c'est une question de niveau mais
c'était ma couleur je faisais tâche vous
avez souffert en arrivant en france de
l'escrim c'est vrai que c'est une
certaine éthique san une certaine
notoriété c'est vrai qu'il y avait pas
beaucoup de noirs dans ce dans ce sport
donc c'est vrai que quand je suis arrivé
sur touche arrivé dans une équipe où il
y avait déjà des piliers qui ne voulait
pas bouger et moi j'arrivais et je vais
j'avais envie de trouver de me prouver
que je n'avais pas quitter mon
département pour rien et vous êtes très
guadeloupe avoue marc bouteiller la
guadeloupe sur vos chaussures et tout ça
avait très sains
quand même vous êtes tous la guadeloupe
indépendante ou non si on peut si ça se
prépare
pourquoi pas mais pour le moment on
n'est pas prêt on n'a pas suffisamment
les reins solides pour faire ça alors
maintenant j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle
pour nous tous ici vous êtes mariés
c'est le coup dur ça arrive comme ça
brutalement
non il ya un truc tu sais que vous dites
quand je me regarde dans un miroir c'est
lui que je vois emballante denis oui
mais derrière ce moment alors par mois
je voyez là c'est à dire que bon
effectivement si le fait d'être marié
enfin là quand même content quand laura
se voit dans un miroir c'est de ne pas
tout le temps se regardant un poster la
patron j'ai eu la chance de trouver un
homme compréhensif parce que c'est vrai
que le stade sud d'accueil de haut
niveau est quand même lourd à gérer
puisque aliments parti lui les
journalistes donc lui aussi de par son
métier les jamais la fin qu'on arrive à
jouer non non on arrive à se retrouver
il c'est vrai que en fait on arrive
d'horizons différents puisqu'il est
d'origine
yougoslave et
et en fait c'est vrai que bon on a quand
même pas mal de temps comment on se
complète fait bien alors de toute façon
il ya plus grave encore que de nice et
après cinéma plus belles médailles ce
sera mon bébé je leur ai assez attendu
oui ça sera toujours conquérir la terre
entière c'est au choix 10 ans une fille
qui aime son jules à ce point là et qui
va bébé de lui et tout apprécié et très
bien au contraire avant tout ça
refroidisse d'une expérience nécessaire
ça vous refroidit pas fabrice qui pousse
et que vous avez dit une chose
magnifique c'est que c'est c'est
fusionnel avec denis là j'avais dire
vous êtes la cause et vous mène quoi oui
c'est bon c'est prodigieux et ça vous
angoisse par moment parce que c'est une
perte de la convaincre trois ans ça vous
envoie ce pas plutôt mais quand vous
êtes lui par moments je pense et lui
voue celui qui gagnent des médailles
d'or dont trois depuis l'attention des
enfants
c'est une émission énorme problème alors
on passait au problème premier problème
vous avez décidé de quitter le racing
club de france qui vous avait accueilli
lorsque vous êtes arrivé de guadeloupe
parce qu'ils veulent plus payer de prime
aux athlètes de haut niveau
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'il
ya une nouvelle politique et la
politique justement renier le sport de
haut niveau
donc ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
scream c'est le sport amateur et que à
cause de ça enfin grâce à ça ça nous
permet d'avoir un certain équilibre
on est obligé de travailler donc on
garde un pied dans la vie active mais ce
qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que on ne
peut pas travailler à 100% donc il ya un
manque à gagner que le club nos données
et le problème qui s'est passé c'est que
à un an des jeux à dix mois des jeux ils
ont ils ont carrément décidé de retirer
son égard moi je pense que c'est c'est
un problème politique
et comme nous le sportif n'avons pas le
temps de s'occuper
regardez votre caméra l'a dit warren
buffet
diplômé 18 profitez-en pendant tout le
monde est au courant
donc en fait on a on a quand même opté
pour rester au club
pendant toute la saison ah bon vous
allez pas vous inscrire à chantilly où
ben c'était la date butoir de
pour changer en fait c'était le 15
novembre la raison pour laquelle on
n'était pas plus avoir aucun petit
lézard mais ça peut s'arranger
ben là on a trouvé un club accueillant
qui quoi au sport de haut niveau et qui
jour justement nous aider donc voilà on
a un championnat incroyable
alors on va c'est le club de quoi
chanter de chantilly ce que je viens de
dire bien donc je dis ça pour les gens
qui me disent quel club en régie alors
on va regarder quelques quelques mais
catherine il faut on va regarder
quelques photos de vous formidable vous
allez m'expliquer ce que ces photos des
regards et comme vous êtes belle alors
c'est après les jeux en 96 jean paul
gaultier donc oui très or la suivante
s'il vous plaît monsieur kalfon voilà
toujours encore c'était la collection
avec l'écho les massaï donc c'est vrai
que je me prêtait à ces photos et c'est
vrai que c'était magnifique
vous êtes très jolie encore une ola la
wii select revient de l'est de la voilà
avec le l'esprit moderne bien
alors maintenant je vous faire comme
c'est la première fois qu'on se voie je
vous faire une interview première fois
locaux